[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
unbelievably the 2020 release of Dragon
Ball Z Kakarot means that we've now had
console games based on the massively
successful manga and anime series for
the last five decades the most recent
time 2018 s Dragon Ball fighters also
happens to be the best of a very large
bunch setting a new benchmark for
recreating the show's spectacularly
kinetic battles albeit within the
confines of a three-on-three fighter
[Music]
Kakarot has no such confines this is
Dragon Ball Z on an unprecedented scale
covering the full nine season anime saga
in such detail that describing it as
comprehensive would be doing it a
disservice
it's an action RPG that retails all of
the major arcs of the series as many DBZ
games have done before but it also
explores never before told backstories
and non-canon scenarios all approved by
crater akira toriyama you're about to
learn the hard way that effort alone
isn't enough to reach my level for the
uninitiated Kakarot is to Goku as kal-el
is to Superman and while that suggests
an adventure devoted solely to the
happy-go-lucky inhumanly powerful Sion
you'll actually get to spend time
controlling other regulars including his
son gohan and arch-nemesis turned
comrades Vegeta and piccolo Dragon Balls
vision of a futuristic earth or dragon
world as it's become known is available
to explore in its entirety and you'll be
grateful that everyone can fly once you
see just how fast it is situated between
DB Z's trademark open plains and rocky
valleys are key areas like West city
calm a house and the sights of the
legendary World Martial Arts Tournament
these are fully explorable and teeming
with NPCs as our incidental locations
such as ginger town whose population was
once fully absorbed by imperfect cell
the series off world locations aren't
ignored either in keeping with Kakarot
s-- beyond faithful adherence to the
source material you'll also travel to
Namak King Kai's tiny planet and even
Dragon Balls decidedly bureaucratic
version of the afterlife of the world of
course one of the main things you'll do
throughout these worlds is engage in ki
blast hurling afterimage dashing meaty
or combination inflicting battles but
we'll save the specifics for a future
video so what else can you get up to
when you're not decimating mountains
with a misplaced spirit bomb
quite
it turns out one of your main jobs
outside of combat is playing at
hunter-gatherer you can hunt wildlife
get the fruits and vegetables and even
try your hand at fishing this being a
dragon ball game though everything's a
little unconventional hunting is less
stealthily taking down a buck with a
rifle and more loudly battering a t-rex
with a Kamehameha while fishing is a
case of Goku using his prehensile monkey
tail which he can now reattach to his
buck for some reason and dangling it in
water until you catch a gigantic flying
catfish and fling it skyward oh and then
you execute a flying kick on the fish to
smash it into the jetty
because Dragon Ball occasionally certain
areas of the world will enter a frenzied
state which means that foraged goods
will be more abundant for a limited time
yes even the humble apple can enter a
frenzied state such is the exaggerated
nature of dragon world the real reason
for performing these activities is tied
to cooking by stopping it campfires
dotted all over the map characters can
rustle up meals that provide useful
temporary stat boosts that can make all
the difference in battle
true to its action RPG status Kakarot is
also rife with side quests and minigames
to keep you distracted from the main
storyline so what if freeze is about to
annihilate Planet Namek when there's
baseball to be played for those who feel
like they've watched and played through
the Dragon Ball Z sagas countless times
already
Kakarot side quests are a major addition
providing new glimpses into the universe
by way of giving minor characters
increased screen time and fleshing out
previously implied or never before
mentioned backstories and events the
game even plays long-overdue homage the
DB Z's filler episodes including fan
favorite Goku's ordeal where our sign
hero and piccolo both attempt to earn
their driving license with predictably
destructive consequences and finally of
course there are the seven titular
Dragon Balls to discover - just like the
series they are scattered far and wide
across the land and by successfully
gathering them all together you'll be
granted one wish by the mighty dragon
Shenron keep an eye out for future
Dragon Ball Z Kakarot videos where we'll
be taking a deep dive into its combat
and looking at the growth and evolution
of its playable characters over the
course of its huge campaign